MY FIRST GUEST AS A VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S QUOTE, DETERMINED TO
SHAPE THE FUTURE TO LOOK LIKE
HIS VERSION OF THE PAST.
THAT HE CRAVES LEGITIMACY.
FIONA HILL HAS BEEN STUDYING
THE RUSSIAN PRESIDENT FOR, MANY
MANY YEARS, AND DURING THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, SHE
SERVED AS A SENIOR DIRECTOR FOR
EUROPEAN AND RUSSIAN AFFAIRS ON
THE NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL.
SHE IS NOW SENIOR FELLOW OF THE
BROOKINGS INSTITUTION, AND HER
LATEST BOOK IS CALLED THERE IS
NOTHING FOR YOU HERE.
FIONA HILL, WELCOME BACK TO OUR
PROGRAM.
LET ME ASK YOU FIRST WHAT YOU
MAKE OF WHAT WE JUST SAW.
RUSSIANS LEAVING TO AVOID THIS
CONSCRIPTION, AND AT THE SAME
TIME, APPARENTLY, A KEY SPIN
DOCTOR ON STATE TELEVISION
CRITICIZING THIS CONSCRIPTION
AND THE MOBILIZATION.
IT'S KIND OF RARE TO HEAR THAT
CRITICISM IN PUBLIC LIKE THAT.
>> WELL, IT'S ALSO FASCINATING,
CHRISTIANE, BECAUSE ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT THE MOBILIZATION
IS TAKING PLACE IS SUPPOSEDLY
PARTIAL MOBILIZATION OF 300,000
PEOPLE, WHICH, OF COURSE, WE
ARE HEARING RUMORS IT MIGHT BE
MANY MORE THAN THAT.
MAYBE EVEN AS MANY AS 1
MILLION.
PART OF THE IMPETUS FOR THAT
WAS HAVING HARD RIGHT, HAWKISH
COMMENTATORS ON RUSSIAN
TELEVISION.
IN FACT, URGING MOBILIZATION.
IF YOU RECALL BACK TO MAY OF
THIS YEAR, WHEN VLADIMIR PUTIN
WAS PRESIDING OVER THE ANNUAL
MAY DAY VICTORY CELEBRATIONS TO
COMMEMORATE THE END OF WORLD
WAR II, THERE WAS A LOT OF
SPECULATION ON THAT DAY OF MAY
9TH THERE WOULD BE A FULL
MOBILIZATION OF THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY.
IN RESPONSE TO THE WAR IN
UKRAINE, AND IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
BECAUSE --
AT THE TIME BELIEVED IT WOULD
BE FAR TOO DIFFICULT FOR PUTIN
TO FULLY MOBILIZE BECAUSE THERE
WOULD BE THIS BACKLASH.
HE HAS BEEN PULLED IN THESE
DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS, HE'S
PULLED HIMSELF IN THESE
DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS, AND WE
ARE NOW ACTUALLY SEEING EXACTLY
WHAT A LOT OF PEOPLE PREDICTED.
THERE WOULD BE A LOT OF
RESISTANCE TO MOBILIZATION.
WHETHER PEOPLE REALLY PREDICT
THAT TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WOULD BE FLEEING ACROSS
THE BORDERS AS, OF COURSE,
ANOTHER QUESTION.
>> WOULD YOU AGREE THAT THIS
TIME HAS THE ADDED ISSUE OF THE
KREMLIN SAYING THAT THE UNITED
STATES IS GETTING, COMING CLOSE
TO BECOMING A PARTY AND WITH
ALL THEIR THREATS AGAINST THAT,
BUT ALSO BUT GIVEN THE FACT
THAT THEY MIGHT USE THIS
ANNEXATION TO THEN DIRECTLY
CONFRONT OR UP THE ANTE
MILITARILY AGAINST THE U.S. OR
NATO, AND EVEN THIS WHOLE IDEA
OF A TACTICAL NUCLEAR WEAPON IN
UKRAINE ITSELF?
>> LOOK.
THERE ARE COMMENTATORS AROUND
THE KREMLIN, MANY OF WHOM
ACTUALLY USED TO WORK IN
WESTERN THINK TANKS GOING
BEYOND THE USE OF A TACKLER
NUCLEAR WEAPON AND USING THE
USE OF A STRATEGIC NUCLEAR
WEAPON AGAINST THE UNITED
STATES OR EVEN ONE OF THEM HAS
GONE AS FAR AS TO SAY POLAND OR
SOME OF THE EUROPEAN COUNTRIES.
LET'S JUST SAY THERE IS A LOT
OF --
GOING ON RIGHT NOW, AND IT'S
ALL PARTS OF THE SAME
OBJECTIVE.
THAT IS TO CHANGE THE
DISCUSSION.
PUTIN DOESN'T LIKE WHAT HAPPENS
ON THE GROUND IN UKRAINE, WITH
THE UKRAINIANS PUSHING BACK AND
BEING ABLE TO RETAKE TERRITORY
AROUND KHARKIV AND SOME OF THE
OTHER REGIONS.
PUTIN WANTS TO CONSOLIDATE WHAT
HE'S ALREADY GOT ON THE GROUND.
HE'S BASICALLY MADE A WHOLE
HOST OF ANNOUNCEMENTS.
FIRST OF ALL, OBVIOUSLY, CRIMEA
IS RUSSIA AND WILL NEVER BE
GIVEN UP.
SECONDS, RECOGNIZING DONETSK
AND LUHANSK, THE TWO
REPUBLICANS THAT MAKE UP THE
DONBAS REGION, EVEN THOUGH
RUSSIAN PROXIES ARE NOT IN FULL
CONTROL OF THOSE REGIONS, SO HE
HAS ANNOUNCED THEM ALREADY ON
THE EVE OF THE INVASION THAT
THEY WERE RECOGNIZED AS
INDEPENDENT.
NOW, HE WANTS TO ANNEX THEM AS
WELL.
AND THE RUSSIANS HAVE MOVED
INTO TWO OF THE MAJOR REGIONS,
KHERSON AND ZAPORIZHZHIA, WHICH
GIVES THEM THEN CONTROL OF ALL
THE INFRASTRUCTURE, INCLUDING
WATER AND ROAD AND RAIL THAT
GROWS INTO CRIMEA.
THEY HAD A REFERENDUM THERE AS
WELL, ON THE QUESTION IS
WHETHER THEY ANNEXED THEM, TO,
BECAUSE PUTIN HAS ALL SAID
RUSSIA IS HERE TO STAY.
HE IS CHANGING THE FACTS ON THE
GROUND.
HE IS DISMEMBERING UKRAINE.
HE IS DIGGING IN, AND NOW HE IS
TRYING TO CHANGE THE WHOLE
DISCUSSION TO MAKE THIS AND THE
GAUTHIER SHAN WITH THE WEST IN
THE UNITED STATES, BECAUSE HE'S
DOING WHAT WE'VE SEEN MANY
TIMES BEFORE, WHICH IS NUCLEAR
THREATS AND REMEMBER, PUTIN HAS
DONE THIS BEFORE IN THE PAST AS
WELL.
HE IS BASICALLY SAYING, NOW HE
WILL HAVE TO NEGOTIATE WITH ME
AND SUE FOR PEACE.
THAT MEANS RECOGNIZING WHAT WE
HAVE DONE ON THE GROUND IN
UKRAINE.
>> CAN I ASK YOU A QUESTION?
REALLY, ABOUT THE TEMPO AND THE
INTENTION OF WHAT WE'VE SEEN,
IS A HUGE HELP BY NATO, THE
WEST, THE UNITED STATES LED,
OBVIOUSLY.
BUT THE FORMER RUSSIAN FOREIGN
MINISTER, ANDRE COSGROVE, SAID
TO ME ON THIS PROGRAM, YOU
CAN'T JUST GO STEP-BY-STEP WHEN
YOU ARE TRYING TO CONFRONT
PUTIN AND GIVE HIM A MESSAGE.
IT HAS TO BE A PUNCH IN THE
NOSE, A PUNCH IN THE FACE.
I WAS WONDERING WHETHER YOU
AGREE WITH THAT, THAT THAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN THE CASE FROM
THE BEGINNING, AND IS THE WEST
LOSING SOME MOMENTUM BY GOING
MORE METHODICALLY, PERHAPS,
THAN THE UKRAINIANS WOULD LIKE?
THEY WOULD LIKE A LOT MORE
SOPHISTICATED AND LONGER RANGE
ARTILLERY, AIRCRAFT, AND A LOT
TO ACTUALLY GIVE THE RUSSIANS
THAT PUNCH IN THE NOSE ON THE
GROUND.
>> LET'S JUST BE VERY CLEAR.
IF THE UKRAINIANS HAVE ALREADY
PUNCHED THEM IN THOSE.
BASICALLY, BY RETAKING KHARKIV
AND PUSHING BACK, AND THIS IS
WHY HE IS RESPONDING.
SO, THE EFFORT FOR, THE FORMER
MINISTER, HE KNOWS WHAT HE'S
SPEAKING OF.
HE WAS WORKING IN THAT CONTEXT
AS WELL.
PEOPLE MIGHT REMEMBER BACK IN
THE EARLY 1990S, HE WAS THE
PERSON WHO ACTUALLY WARNED THE
WEST THAT THE HARD-LINERS WERE
COMING BACK INTO POWER IN BORIS
YELTSIN.
SO, HE'S SOMEBODY STEEPED IN
THESE LARGER DYNAMICS.
HE'S NOT WRONG.
OF COURSE, THE DILEMMA OR THE
U.S. AND HAS BEEN TRYING TO
CONTAIN THIS CONFLICT.
I THINK WE ARE NOW THE HOME
FRONT AS WELL.
BUT THIS BUSINESS PANDEMIC WAS
INEVITABLE THAT WE WOULD GET TO
THIS PLACE.
ALSO, I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE UP
AND QUESTIONING WHAT WE HAVE TO
NEGOTIATE, WE HAVE TO PAY AN
AWFUL LOT OF ATTENTION TO WHAT
RUSSIA IS ASKING FOR, BUT THAT
WON'T SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
WE ARE NOW IN A DYNAMIC WHICH
HAS ALL KINDS OF GLOBAL KNOCK
ON EFFECTS.
AGAIN, THE POINT HERE IS THAT
PUTIN SEASON HAS SEEN FOR A
VERY LONG TIME THAT HE IS A
DIRECT STRUGGLE WITH THE WEST.
FOR HIM, UKRAINE IS JUST PART
OF THE.
HE'S BEEN SAYING THIS SINCE
2007, 2008, BEING IN THE
SITUATION EFFECTIVELY SINCE THE
ANNEXATION OF UKRAINE IN 2014.
IT'S INCUMBENT UPON US RIGHT
NOW TO SHORE UP OUR OWN
RESILIENCE.
WE MUST IN TURN, PROVIDE THE
UNITY AND BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT
IS HAPPENING RIGHT HERE.
PUTIN THINKS HE'S LOST
MOMENTUM.
HE'S TRIED TO TAKE IT.
HE IS TRYING TO PUSH FORWARD IN
EVERY FRONT HE CAN.
HE BELIEVES THAT WE WILL
CAPITULATE.
SO, WHAT HE'S TRYING TO DO NOW
IS NOT JUST TURN THE TIDE ON
THE GROUND IN UKRAINE, BUT HE'S
TRYING TO TURN THE TIDES OF THE
CAPITALS OF EVERY EUROPEAN AND
U.S. SUPPORTER OF UKRAINE.
HE IS BASICALLY TRYING TO SAY,
YOU ARE NOW AWE --
WHAT HE'S DOING HERE IS THIS IS
COMPLETE AND OTHER NUCLEAR
BLACKMAIL WITH THE TACTICAL AND
STRATEGIC NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF THINGS IN
THE PAPER SAYING IT'S LIKE THE
CUBAN MISSILE CRISIS.
THIS ABSOLUTELY ISN'T.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE UNITED
STATES OR THE WEST MANEUVERING
NEW CATEGORIES OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
THIS IS, PURE AND SIMPLE,
VLADIMIR PUTIN LOSING HIS PLACE
ON THE BATTLEFIELD AND TRYING
TO BLACKMAIL US ALL INTO
CAPITULATING.
IT'S NO DIFFERENT FROM WHAT KIM
JONG-UN HAS BEEN DOING IN NORTH
KOREA.
SO, WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE NOW
EXACTLY WHAT WE DID.
>> IT'S REALLY INTERESTING.
YOU'RE SAYING IT'S NO DIFFERENT
FROM WHAT KIM JONG-UN --
AND WHEN HE'S FACED WITH A
STRONG RESPONSE, TENDS TO BACK
OFF, KIM JOHN.
HE HASN'T FOLLOWED THROUGH WITH
ANY OF HIS THREATS AND
RHETORIC.
BUT WHAT DO YOU THINK PUTIN
WILL DO?
HE SAID HE IS NOW THROWING
EVERYTHING AT ITS, AND HE HOPES
THE WEST WILL CAPITULATE.
DO YOU THINK THERE IS A POINT
AT WHICH THE WEST WILL
CAPITULATE?
YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT THE
ENERGY.
WE KNOW THAT PEOPLE IN THE WEST
ARE HURTING, PARTICULARLY IN
EUROPE, NOT SO MUCH OF THE
UNITED STATES, WITH ENERGY AND
PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD, WITH
FOOD INSECURITY, ALL COMING
FROM THIS PROBLEM.
CAN YOU SEE, DESPITE THE STRONG
RHETORIC COMING FROM THE EU,
FOR INSTANCE, THAT UNITY CRACK
UNDER THIS, AS YOU CALL IT,
BLACKMAIL AND PRESSURE WITH
ENERGY?
>> WELL, IF YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT IT, WHEN RECOGNIZING WHAT
HE IS DOING AND WHY HE'S DOING
IT, RIGHT?
HE OBVIOUSLY CALCULATES THAT WE
WILL.
SO, WE HAVE TO SHOW HIM THAT WE
WILL NOT.
THERE IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE A
MULTI PRONGED APPROACH ON THE
ENERGY FRONT, ON ISSUES RELATED
TO FOOD SECURITY, AND ALSO ON
CONTINUING TO SUPPORT UKRAINE.
ALSO, VERY IMPORTANTLY, THE
UNITED STATES IS NO LONGER THE
ONLY NUCLEAR POWER IN THE
WORLD.
CHINA'S OWN NUCLEAR POWER.
OF COURSE, THE UNITED KINGDOM
AND FRANCE ARE PART OF THE
NUCLEAR POWERS THAT CAME OUT OF
WORLD WAR II.
BUT WE HAVE INDIA, WE HAVE
PAKISTAN, CHINA'S ARSENAL IS
BUILDING EVEN FURTHER, THERE'S
A LOT OF OTHER COUNTRIES OF,
COURSE, THAT NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
THIS IS THEM REQUIRING A
MULTINATIONAL APPROACH.
AND THE CASE OF KIM JONG-UN,
THAT WE ALREADY TALKED ABOUT,
CHINA PLAYED A VERY IMPORTANT
ROLE IN CONSTRAINING HIS
ABILITY TO DO THINGS.
WE NEED TO KEEP WORKING WITH
CHINA, WITH INDIA, AND OTHER
NUCLEAR POWERS TO PUSH BACK
AGAINST THIS.
JUST TO SAY THAT PUTIN DOES
THIS, WHICH WE HAVE TO TAKE
SERIOUSLY, USES A NUCLEAR
WEAPON, THIS WILL IMBALANCE
STRATEGIC STABILITY GLOBALLY.
NOT JUST IN EUROPE, BUT
GLOBALLY.
>> I THINK IT WILL SET OFF A
SENSE OF CHAIN REACTIONS
POLITICALLY, BUT UNINTENDED
HERE, ON EVERY FRONT.
SO, I THINK WE ARE NOT GOING TO
BE THE ONLY INTERESTED PARTIES
HERE.
MAKING THAT POINT, ASKED THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN, WE
ALSO HEARD FROM PRIME MINISTER
MODI OF INDIA THAT THIS IS A
TIME OF PEACE AND NOT FOR WAR,
BUT MAKING THE POINT FOR THESE
FURTHER CONSEQUENCES IS
ESSENTIAL.
KEEPING IN AND PUSHING THE
NATURE INTERNATIONAL DIPLOMACY
IS PART OF THIS AS WELL.
IT'S INCUMBENT UPON US TO
BASICALLY STAND UP TO THIS AND
NOT TO, BASICALLY, CAPITULATES.
OF COURSE, HE IS GOING TO KEEP
ON PRESSING AND RECOGNIZING
WHAT HE'S DOING, I THINK, IS
PART OF THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE
TO PUSH BACK AGAIN.